well so much to talk to the Tory pier
and pollster Lord hey what about this
morning good morning my lord always a
pleasure to see you let's tackle that
first of all
um a very very wealthy multi-millionaire
prime minister what does that do to the
polls everybody knows he's rich man who
married well
um he's got a big income but he's
disclosed it and people have to judge it
on that basis but it doesn't come as a
surprise that he's a rich man what about
the former prime minister in front of
the Privileges committee yesterday what
does that do to Tory uh popularity I
think it muddies the waters there's no
question about that Rishi sunak's trying
to get a clear message of competence and
managerial expertise as a prime minister
and every time this issue comes back uh
people are reminded of the chaos that
there was in the Tory party last last
year what about if we fast forward and
there is potentially a by-election what
sort of problems might that cause for
the Tories in the polls oh it would
cause serious problems
um the party doesn't want to
buy-election
um my guess is that if there were a
by-election certainly on current polls
we would lose the constituency and
therefore
um it's something that is there but we
can't prejudge what the committee will
decide how popular is Boris Johnson
still amongst the rank and file I think
his support is diminishing and the vote
yesterday in terms of the national
Northern Ireland protocol okay yeah but
his his support is diminishing his
impact on the party is diminishing the
longer that Rishi sunak is prime
minister
um if he was parachuted into another
suit he might lose Oxbridge there are
lots of seats that would have him
potentially Henley where he was
previously what impact would that have
on the polls I've I don't think he would
want to do that to be honest yeah
because it can you imagine Boris as
leader of the opposition that if he
loses that seat and the Tory party lost
the general election I meant with the
by-election and the name is running in
the general in the general election but
I don't think that's in his nature
um I don't think he would want to
actually be parachuted into another
place with a serious Prospect and one
has to recognize the polls may be
improving but they're not improving that
much at the moment he would be
potentially leader of the opposition and
that's not something that Boris would
either want to do or be good at I don't
think he did say the polls are improving
yes they are there's been a progressive
upward slope and also shown in Council
by-elections but the Tory party are
nowhere near Out of the Woods as yet so
it's improving from a very very
difficult position what do they need to
do we looked at the interest rate
figures not the interest rate the
inflation figures yesterday they were
expected to be in single figures for the
first time in a while they weren't they
weren't and I think the important impact
of that you identified the impact on
mortgage people who pay mortgages but it
also as far as I'm concerned is a very
clear indication that inflation is going
to going to take longer to tackle than
we've we hoped it would and that puts
the election back I'm quite clear now it
will be in the Autumn of 2024. so you're
saying that we won't see and the next
general election unless I mean obviously
a week's a long time in politics
um until somebody famously wants it
until October of 2020. absolutely
October November 2024 the inflation
figures as far as I'm concerned made
that absolutely clear that some people
were talking about earlier than that but
I think the indications are that
inflation and therefore interest rates
and all that goes with that
means a very clear message you can plan
for an Autumn 2024 election what is the
mood in the House of Commons across the
road on both sides I'm sure you have
friends
the mood has changed there's no question
about that the atmospherics following on
from the budget the Northern Ireland
protocol vote
Etc have changed there is you could talk
to Tory MPS they were we're going to
lose I may lose my seat it's a disaster
labor we're virtually measuring up for
the curtains the atmosphere has changed
there's a degree of uncertainty
and I had a liberal Democrat tell me
that they'd actually put money on no
overall majority uh only a few days ago
is that a good bit
um
I think it's risky still uh the likely
hoodies that you would expect labor to
win the next election but I think the
prospects of that are becoming less
certain now you mentioned the Northern
Ireland protocol vote it wasn't on the
whole protocol War said oh that the
Windsor I forget what all these things
are called the winter framework it
wasn't on that it was just a one
particular aspect the Stormont break is
what it was called and that's what the
um the House of Commons voted on
yesterday it was a cakewalk really for
the Prime Minister but what he easily
won that vote but what struck me is that
two previous Prime Ministers both voted
against it very striking but the biggest
political impact there was how small the
Rebellion actually was the Boris and his
trusts were in a very small group of
people
um probably the key figure was around 40
in terms of potential Rebels because if
the figure had been at that level you
could say the Prime Minister had to rely
on on labor and live Dem support and he
didn't have to it was half that figure
and six percent of the conservative MPS
rebelling voting against that's a very
small number the the Tory party in
Parliament it's another function of
Rishi sunak's Prime ministerial role is
they're rediscovering unity and they're
actually quite enjoying it I was talking
to one MP last night and really he's
actually used the phrase that he was
happy to come to work at last and they'd
use that rediscovering of unity not
descend after what is what seven eight
nine years of arguing about brexit
arguing about leaderships arguing about
everything you shouldn't get too
comfortable though should be looking at
what the dup erupt nobody should ever be
comfortable in politics
um a day let alone a week is a long time
so don't get too comfortable at any
point okay and don't run for the tube my
Lord because we can see what happens got
your leg in a brace thank you it's good
to talk to you thank you thank you